desde hace dos años se deben realizar la
limpieza de los huesos de su hermano
mario en los días previos a la
celebración de los fieles difuntos los
usuarios se pintan y los familiares
sacan un baúl en el que han depositado
los restos de sus fallecidos con una
brocha van limpiando uno a uno los
huesos de los que ya no están
físicamente como acto de amor más que
nada porque
en un ejemplo cuando tú tienes a un
familiar
que no puede valerse por sí
y tú haces todo lo posible para que él
se vea bien y pueda salir es un ritual
milenario que se realiza en el estado
mexicano de campeche y se llama limpieza
de los santos restos socios los restos
de las personas que fallecen son
exhumados tres años después de su muerte
y son depositados en un baúl sobre una
manta especial que los familiares se
encargan a las bordadoras de la
localidad el proceso como mayormente
pues a tiempo muchos lo conocemos es la
limpieza de los pies hacia la cabeza
porque sabemos que terrenal mente en las
personas en vida palpamos el mundo
exterior por los pies por la tierra
entonces ellos al regresar tienen que
entrar caminando además de la limpieza
de huesos las fotos de los difuntos se
exhiben en plazas públicas y en las
casas donde se levantan altares
decorados con platillos bebidas y
objetos que los difuntos amaban en vida
es una costumbre que se hereda hay
algunos elementos gráficos en algunos
libros que firmaban los en comendador es
por ahí de mil 637 mil seiscientos mil
siete entre mil seis mil setecientos
donde narran justamente en algunos
escritos que hay pueblos donde
acostumbran a hacer la limpieza de estos
de las osamentas para los mayas la
muerte solo era un ciclo más en el
universo un reencuentro con sus dioses y
en estas fechas el regreso con el mismo
permiso de sus dioses para volver al
plano terrenal al menos por unos días